you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 27
from the beginner to chess master
playlist a progressive series of videos
that is slowly developing the topic here
is tactical awareness in this position
it's black to move and the rule is if
you're going to take the following test
to spend no more than 30 seconds on this
position black to move what would you do
okay times up those of you who spend
some time with this especially those who
are fishing for a tactic forgive me 1
does not exist ok why would I do this to
you why am i starting a video saying
it's regarding tactical awareness and
then throwing a dud your way a position
absent of a tactic well this is
something all chess players experience
isn't it of course there isn't always a
tactic
well we train tactics by way of a book
or online of course we know there's a
tactic there but we don't have that
luxury doing when we play now a common
question I'll receive go something like
this
how do I know if there's a tactic when I
play it's a good question and one I am
looking to help you to answer when you
play so how am I going to do this well
I'm going to share with you conditions
that I look for kind of tactical red
flags that helped me to know not when a
tactic is there because I can't say that
with certainty but what I can say what I
feel strongly about is that the more of
these conditions that are present the
more likely a tactic is present now this
video what is it not it is not intended
to be some big test the positions the
examples I share with you are primarily
covering simple tactics and by simple I
do not mean easy I dislike that word by
simple I mean two three move
combinations by sharing these examples
these positions the main idea is to
simply open up a dialogue I want to be
able to
share how I think through positions what
is it about these positions that is
capturing my attention so with that said
let's have a look at our first example
oh and another thing even though it is
not intended to be some big test I do
feel that you would you will take the
most from this video if you do treat it
as a test so when prompted with the
phrases white to move or black to move
or some other question be ready to
quickly hit that pause button okay
they're not all going to be tests though
this one here is not a test what is one
of the conditions I look for when
scanning a position for tactics well I'm
in particular drawn to my opponents King
so I'll playing white in this position
I'm certainly drawn to the location of
my opponents King and any other piece
that may be on the same let's say file
in this case King and a bishop on the
same file is subjected to a fork same
arrangement the only thing that has
changed is the rook position subjected
to a pin the bishop will soon be one and
of course we have the skewer tactic
these should all be familiar terms with
you I have already covered them same
story if they're on the diagonal
position of pieces fork pin skewer same
story two bishops on the same rank okay
there could be a problem there whenever
a pawn lands a fork what must be there
two enemy pieces on the same rank that's
necessary I think about the position of
pieces that's one condition
and when I say position of pieces I'm
thinking about lines and I'm thinking
about colors what in the world am I
talking about when I say colors I'll get
to that shortly
position of pieces and a
other thing that I think about our pins
I just shared with you several instances
of a pin fork and a skewer why is it
that pins stick out to me more than
anything else
well pins kind of linger in a position a
fork is you know a knight Lanza fork
your opponent moves and then you make a
move and win material a skewer you land
the skewer your opponent makes a move
you Bank some material over done with
pins on the other hand they're
constantly just they're in a position
and the position evolves being attentive
to pins is very important now before I
look at some specific examples regarding
pins what's this talk about me being
attentive to colors well I found when
preparing for this video
something interesting regarding the
Knights so I'm just going to share with
you maybe you benefit from it believe it
or not I have actually improved somewhat
tactically through this video through
preparing for this video so here it goes
the king and the Queen same file in this
case or of course subjected to a knight
fork it could be on the same rank
another fork diagonal fork and they
could be next to it money next to one
another on a diagonal another fork this
is part of what makes a knight tricky
though our mind has a tendency to think
along lines right files ranks diagonals
but the knight is that one magical piece
that could still land a fork even if the
pieces aren't on the same file or rank
9c3 in this case Knight c3 in this case
king and queen different location you'll
notice something though with all of
these examples I just shared with you
with the night and it just zipping
through here do you notice anything that
is similar
they're all in the same color right in
order for these forks to come about they
all have to be on the same color square
so this is why it is helpful for me to
think more about the night think more
kind of color code color coat the night
and then color code the night and I'm
not thinking about this all the time
I'll try to be a bit more specific but
before I get to these specifics one
quick little tip in this position the
king is in check one of the most secure
squares for the King to go to is efore
in this position Y same diagonal 1
square separating them why is this one
of the most secure squares well it's
going to take the knight three steps
before it could deliver check to the
king I imagine many of you already know
this but if not I think it's a pretty
cool tip to be familiar with any other
square besides e for the knight can
deliver check that much faster any light
square the knight immediately lands a
check and any dark square the knight is
only going to have to take two steps to
land a check efore different story it's
going to take three steps now once more
drawing your attention to the colors of
the night this is when I think about
those colors what color square my night
is on and then I'm just kind of scanning
to see what color squares my opponent's
pieces are on my night is on light does
my opponent have two or more pieces that
are on our white square when do I do
this primarily when the night is on
ranks four and five now why of all
squares or ranks do these stick out to
me more than any other well this is when
the knight is within reach of that back
rank and we know what pieces start out
in that back rank and are often there
for sometime
yeah this is when the knight can land
something pretty devastating right
Knight d6 winning some material with no
forking to rooks and of course if it
happens on rank fork and
and on rank five these are the primary
ranks that stick out to me 97 win
something good now what have I just done
with this position something asked an
interesting question in video 3 of this
series I closed out that video saying
what square is a best square for a light
night or what squares of best square for
a black night and I never really
intended someday to answer that question
but I think I kind of have an answer to
that
um these positions you see here for the
white night I think they're the best
squares for a white night I think
they're the most threatening squares to
an enemy King has it as it concerns as
it relates to the enemy King I think a
knight on d5 and f5 are most threatening
to the black King why well from these
the only two squares where regardless of
where the king is on castled Castle
kingside Castle queenside these are the
only two squares where the knight still
has two different moves that could give
check to the king regardless of where
the king is castled or uncle a white
knight on a white square is very
dangerous to the enemy King similarly a
black knight on a black square is very
dangerous to the enemy King now these
two simple phrases Believe It or Not
have been helpful to me in quickly
recognizing tactical ideas towards the
enemy King maybe it'll be helpful for
you I'm just throwing it out there
something that was helpful for me that's
how I see the board I think more of
colors I think more so about colors then
lines regarding the Knights now let's
have an example
position here right out of the opening
okay what is going on exactly
blacks threatening mate it's defended as
soon as this is on board I'm thinking
Queen King one day I want a bishop on b5
that can happen very easily d6 would be
a great blunder Bishop b5 is going to
pick up the Queen okay let's say black
is better than that I'm not sure how
much better but instead of d6 let's say
black plays h6 when the knight jumps
into d5 this is again ranks four and
five this is where I'm thinking more
about those colors knight on a light I'm
looking at enemy pieces that may also be
on light we have more than enough black
pieces on the same color square as the
knight in this case a tactic can be
nearby d6 in this case it may appear is
not a blunder right Bishop b5 does not
have the knight support now but really
it does Bishop b5 can still be played
and after Queen takes bishop there we go
that would be a massive fork so again
Knights I think about colors especially
when it jumps into ranks four and five
now the other P word was um pins this is
your first pop-quiz white to move what
would you do okay here we go best move
is
f 6 that's a check and if they can goes
to the corner clean H 7 is checkmate and
if the night is captured it's still
going to lead to checkmate based on this
condition pin pon can't take the Queen
the King s to go to the corner and rook
H 1 check me so this little checkmate
sequence maintance 3 is based on one
simple condition this pin being alert to
a pin can lead to many good things let's
have a look at another one white to move
what move would you play in this
position okay now this one doesn't
result in something big like the last
puzzle checkmate this is much more
technical than just a small result here
a good move for white is to simply play
Knight to deform a move that is
available it's tactically there based on
the pin of the e pawn all right nope
nope on takes Knight because you lose
the Queen so after the Queen gets out of
the pin now knight c6 okay white isn't
gaining any material but white is
certainly improved the knight a piece
that is far more invasive on c6 than f3
let's go on to another example actually
just to kind of get warmed up here in
this position it's black to move what
would you do okay like to move best move
is to take on g3 we're just getting
warmed up here Queen takes g3 rook takes
h3 and in the end Queen takes Knight
this was a checkmate in three puzzle
this wasn't regarding pins just getting
warmed up just curious to know what you
would do in this position is black if
you spot a queen takes g3 great
checkmate in three position let's go on
to another one white to move what would
you do okay here we go
this right here sticks out to me in this
was
the rook and the king same diagonal and
also the Queen is pinning the pawn to
the Queen
so this pawn is powerless that's how I
see this this pawn doesn't really have
the ability to make a capture best move
in this position is Bishop to d5
basically winning everything you know
good solution here for team black so
that's the winning shot it's just a
simple idea based on the the position of
the king and rook in this case and also
this pin let's have a look at another
position right here black to move okay
the best move in this position is Queen
to g3 this position should look very
familiar to that puzzle I showed just
two positions ago really wasn't a
warm-up but rather just kind of a test
to see how you're seeing the board right
if you if you forgot what that other
position look like this is this is the
position right where you take here take
here and then give checkmate you're
doing the same thing in this position
right here but you know I'm just kind of
doing that as a feeler for you know I
don't know maybe you could benefit if
you're if you're able to get the first
one but you're not seeing this one you
know just as let's say you know clearly
maybe you're your focus on pins isn't
there yet okay Queen g3 it's just the
same sequence based on this little pin
let's have a look at another example in
this position white just played the move
d5 black to move what would you do okay
this is a poor move by white because it
puts this pawn in a pin in okay we just
take out a knight here's something to
look for when your opponent makes a move
now so far I've just shared with you a
position of pieces I'm touching on pins
as well
um when your opponent makes a move are
they maybe how are they may be
tactically vulnerable well there's a new
condition present with this last move
isn't there it went from you know a
position where there isn't a pin against
the king to one where yeah now there is
a pin
how can you maybe take advantage of this
let that be your cue to maybe see these
little tactical ideas going from you
know position a to position B in other
words their where's my opponent
deficient any weaknesses tactical
weaknesses left behind with my opponents
last move okay another position white to
move what would you do okay this is a
checkmate sequence here we go Knight b6
taking advantage of a pin the Queen
swings over black hit only block and
that's actually pretty cool checkmate
one last one on the topic of pins in
this position oh this is a yeah this is
an interesting one I was watching a a
game not too long ago and yeah this is
what happened you ready for this one
white played rook to g1 now granted this
is a you know a faster time control game
so you know as you have to move faster
accidents are going to happen but this
was a clear example of a player being
you know not aware of pins the rook
played to g1 this happened okay I'm not
sure if I have the exact all the pieces
exactly where they were in the game but
this this very idea happened you ready
rook g1 black repositioned the knight
alright there wasn't anything fancy
going on in the forward and yeah after
rook g1 black needed to recognize
there's a pin here what did white do as
a follow up well they're able to take on
h6 at this point what did black do black
saw okay now there's problem here so
they wanted to shield that pressure and
they played Knight g6 there's a pin here
is well light was able to follow up with
that move rook takes Knight a clear sign
that team white was well aware of pins
in the position and white clearly was
not okay moving on to some examples
regarding position of pieces so again
thinking lines the the arrangement of
pieces the the alignment of pieces and
also the Knights thinking about the
color squares for the Knights white to
move what would you do okay best move in
this position is Queen takes Bishop
Queen takes Queen and what condition do
we have here light light light there's a
knock out Knight takes Bishop Knight
takes Queen and if you have lost track
white with that sequence has won a minor
piece let's have a look at another
example black to move what would you do
okay here we go Knight on dark Queen on
dark how can we create a condition where
the king is on dark rook in the corner
King takes rook boom another fork is
present let's have a look at another
example black to move what would you do
okay another situation all three are
there on a dark square no way to really
get here for a fork but there's a way to
force the King on a different dark
Square Queen takes h2 is the star move
and after King takes Queen three pieces
all in the same color square Knight
takes Bishop another fork on board
another one white to move in this
position what would you do okay here we
go
dark dark how to force the King on a
dark is what I would be thinking h7 is
the way to do it
give up the bishop but
conditions are now set to land a fork
just three more here this is where it
can start to get a little bit more
involved black to move what would you do
okay yeah again this one is a little bit
more sophisticated the move here is
Knight d5 hanging the Queen seems like
you could take the knight not so fast
you lose the Queen what is the trick
here exactly well after Queen takes
Queen there is now this condition and
the bishop falls and then the Queen
black is banking a minor piece with that
sequence another example here light to
move what would you do
okay now with this example what are we
doing we are creating a certain
condition currently there are no pins
but after the move rook to h8 well first
off if the knight takes it's going to
lead to checkmate so after rook H a king
takes what is black now in black is in a
pin is there a way to exploit it you can
be sure there is in this case how do we
do this
Queen h6 check and Queen takes g7 cool
little to move combination there to be
familiar with based on one little simple
condition a pin one last example and
then we're going to move on to a
different condition this one's a bit
trickier black to move what would you do
okay a bit bit trickier a bit more
technical that's probably the better
word to use a best move here for black
is to place c4 what is c4 doing well
it's forcing the bishop to a square
where it's unprotected and because of
the bishop being unprotected there's now
a pin and because of this pin there's a
new move available what does that move
Knight to d5 and after Knight to d5
there simply is not a good solution to
the attack on c3 no good solution so
this is the this is the main trick here
c4 mind you you know if this pieces
capture this pawn is captured the e4
pawn would fall and yeah Black is for
choice in this position but the idea is
to create a situation where your
opponent is now in a pin and look for a
way to maybe take advantage of it know
that this pawn is powerless in a
particular way in this case still has
strength capturing in this direction but
not this direction it's not really
covering d5 because of this pin okay so
just a quick recap position of pieces I
think lines
I think colors and also of the forks
pins and skewers I am primarily focused
on the pins because they are something
that kind of linger in a position just
kind of stick around in positions okay
what is this next topic
what is this next condition it is
unprotected pieces okay now if you've
been connected with me for some time I
devoted a video specifically to just
this condition I believe I titled it
chess awareness test it's like a
seven-year-old video yeah so I'm kind of
you know recapping what I shared in that
video with these next couple puzzles so
unprotected pieces is a great tactical
liability in this position black just
played the move Bishop to g4 White is in
a pin what would you do in reply to this
move feel free to pause the video okay
many players I believe would recognize
this as a pin
and try to do something about it maybe
connect nights maybe question the bishop
this is something that captures my
attention first I see it as a pin in my
mind kind of immediately goes to trying
to do something about the pin it's like
I categorized that move as a pin and
then I'm kind of blinded to maybe other
ideas that may be present it's not a bad
thing to see this move as a pin but I
think we can do one better I think I
could do one better if I see this also
as my opponent making a move with a
piece that was protected and now you
know placing it on a square where it is
unprotected this is a move that white
can punish unprotected pieces have zero
attackers and zero defenders and
similarly I view unprotected pieces as
having one attacker and one defender now
that may take some work for you to also
view the board like that these are
sensitive squares okay zero attackers
zero defenders one attacker one defender
in this position right here we have
three rooks that are unprotected not
really a way to take advantage of the
rooks being unprotected right when the
position when when the game begins what
do we have for unprotected rooks
everything else is defended I don't
focus so much on the rooks but these
other moves going from a protected
square to an unprotected square now that
that's something that captures my
attention the bishop is unprotected the
pawn is unprotected can't really take
advantage of that but regarding this one
attacker one defender idea f7 is also
sensitive and this is where white can
pounce with the move Bishop takes f7
pulling the king out so that the knight
actually can move with check and then
what can I do pick up this unprotected
piece a simple and effective tactic that
is based on unprotected pieces moving on
to not that example this one right here
let's see what we have just going
through the opening phase now again in
the beginning the rooks are unprotected
but I'm again not looking so much at the
rooks you know how to maybe attack the
rooks but certain moves make me think
about ways to maybe attack the rook so
for example black on move it's the
development stage black may be saying
well my bishop it's not gonna come out
this way let's Fein Quetta the bishop b6
is a serious blunder because white is
able to get on this diagonal before the
bishop is able to get on the diagonal
how well by capturing the night
what's unprotected the rook and this
pawn right here one attacker one
defender
Queeny for would be game over black has
to safeguard the king with g6 and yeah
there goes rook simple tactic based on
unprotected pieces now we just saw an
example where the Queen took took a step
up right right here Queen to e4 got on
this diagonal before black at fianchetto
very often I believe you will take
advantage of an unprotected rook when
your opponent starts to get aggressive
with one of the rooks when the game
begins the rooks are disconnected and
after that they usually become connected
that's one of the benefits you get by
castling right in developing your pieces
that's you know your your protect
rooks one day by getting your pieces
developed at some point though it can
happen that your books become
disconnected and this often happens once
one rook takes a step up in this
position white plays the move rook f3
looking for some caveman-like attack
looking for checkmate on h7 at this very
moment the rook is now unprotected
there's a way to take advantage of that
in this case with Queen to d4 and there
goes the rook in the game for white a
simple tactic what am I really looking
for here when over a rook takes a step
up that's a red flag to me that sticks
out to me is there a way to maybe take
advantage of a rook post is a rook being
is a rook now unprotected in this case
yeah let's have a look at another
example this one is pulled straight from
one of the games I've played online
I was playing his wipe my opponent
played rook to a5 and I saw this pawn as
a weakness so I said I'm going to target
it and I did that by making a rook lift
I played rook to d3 my opponent
fortunately did not spot a good reply
here can you see what it is black to
move okay a good move here for black is
to play Bishop takes f5 with my last
move I left of rook unprotected on e1 if
I capture
the bishop then yeah I'm gonna lose the
rook I'm in a pin my rook is now
unprotected on a one I'm not sure why
this is the case whenever I look to
double up on let's say the D file I have
a tendency to move the D rook up and
then the other rook over but if I was
more attentive to pieces being
unprotected when I was playing this
position this game I would have done it
like this rook III it's still gonna take
two moves one way or the other but this
is a more efficient way this is one that
is more tactically sound so you might
want to keep this in mind when you're
making a little rook lift looking to
double in what order should you do it
for whatever the reason I think most
players do it like this rook up and then
the other one you know you move the
piece that's already on the file you
want to ultimately double on and then
you come over with the other one instead
of this way anyhow moving on to another
example here we go Black's last move is
Knight to d7 pop-quiz white to move what
would you do okay here we go
Black's last move has left black
tactically vulnerable I'm sure from you
know here experienced player right now
listening in you have experienced this
and many of the other examples I've
already shared yeah Bishop is
unprotected with blacks last move and
this can be taken advantage of
Knight takes f7 or even Knight takes c6
is working throwing a punch at the Queen
one way or the other I like Nick takes
f7 yeah with this little sequence what
has what has white done White's one Upon
A to B care
about you know when you make a move with
a piece is that piece now unprotected or
maybe are you creating a situation where
other pieces are unprotected in this
case yeah you are Bishop on d6 is
vulnerable moving on to another one okay
here we go now whites last move is d5
pop-quiz black to move what would you do
okay now this one you have to be careful
with your knight is under fire and you
may be very tempted to move it
immediately but doing so is not a good
idea if you move this Knight let's say
here or here the bishop on b4 is now
unprotected and it can be tactically
vulnerable right Queen to a4 it's with
check and the bishop will fall so what
you must do is recognize hang on if I
move my knight my Bishop is unprotected
and this kind of move is having an
influence on the state of this b4 bishop
yeah you have to take the knight first
and only then react to this threat
careful moving on to another example
this is another one pulled from one of
my games
I was playing black here and made a poor
move Bishop to e4 white to move what
move could white play here fortunately
my opponent didn't find this move white
to move what would you do okay Bishop on
e4 is unprotected knight on a5 is
unprotected and the star move in this
position is Queen to e1 striking it both
of these unprotected pieces there's no
way out really if Bishop takes Knight
white would take the knight here hitting
the Queen and only then recapture in the
end white would be winning a minor piece
I was very lucky my opponent did not
spot the Queen to e1 move but had they
been more attentive to the unprotected
pieces
if I was more attentive to the
unprotected pieces in this game yeah I
shouldn't have been playing Bishop to e4
okay black to move what would you do
okay
seems like a pretty innocent position
but the bishop on b5 unprotected there
is this fancy move Knight takes e5 if
Knight takes Knight you take the bishop
black wins upon and if Bishop takes
Bishop the knight circles back I don't
know that this has a specific name but I
know I think maybe assigning the name
Boomerang that kind of comes to mind for
me the knight kind of you know coming
out like this and then circling back for
a recapture it's based on that
unprotected bishop and this can happen
in many different angles right after
Bishop to b4 it's the same story here
just on the other side of the board
bishops unprotected we once again have
this little tactic Knight takes bishop
takes in the knight circles back to
recapture one more example here this is
where it gets a little bit more you have
to calculate maybe a little bit more
with these after the move h6 what move
would you play in this position as white
Bishop takes Knight or Bishop h4 okay it
would be better to take the knight than
to go to h4 if you go to h4 the bishop
is now unprotected that should be a red
flag and you are vulnerable to the white
would be vulnerable to the move Knight
takes e4 there is no time to take the
bishop because of Knight takes Queen
with check and so after Knight takes
Knight black takes the bishop black has
just won upon with that sequence moving
on to another example let's say we see
what we have here out of the opening
unprotected
pieces yeah this is a familiar one
blacken move has an unprotected bishop
black has with this last move just
castled white to move what's a good move
here for white okay there's nothing
fancy going on against that bishop but
with this one attacker one defender this
is a familiar pattern to sacrifice a
bishop and then go in for an attack
against the king with the Queen and the
knight you know one of the conditions
when f6 is under control and that Knight
isn't around to defend here yeah very
often there could be a problem when you
point the bishop at h7 in this position
there certainly is a problem Queen and
Knight are in this particular case
delivering checkmate with this sequence
so it's just based on one little weak
point
h7 being vulnerable in this case it's
unprotected now but yeah once it's the
king who has to be the defender and
lured out after the castles move that's
a problem okay let's go on to another
one
pop quiz black to move what would you do
okay here we go a tactic based on the
bishop on f5 so what do we have
Knight takes e5 and after Bishop takes
Bishop black has this in-between move
sidestepping the threat against the
night lands a check and only then scoops
the bishop up Black has one upon so
there's these in-between moves in the
game whites last move is Queen c2 pop
quiz black to move what would you do
okay now there's an open diagonal this
has my attention and with the move b5
Black is forcing White's Bishop to an
unprotected square so now we're trying
to create conditions where your opponent
has an unprotected piece Bishop is far
more vulnerable on b5 than a 4 this pawn
sac
sets up in ensuing check against the
king in of course against the king a
check and then yeah you pick up the
unprotected bishop another example black
to move what would you do
okay similar idea c4 in this position
after Bishop takes pawn the bishop is
now unprotected and there's a new square
available for the Queen
so Queen c5 check and then Queen or even
Bishop wins apiece we're creating
conditions no white on move has just
played d3 what would you do as black
okay here we go
best move efore White's last move left
the knight unprotected and there's no
good solution here Knights under fire
both Knights are under fire one is gonna
go down no good solution pawn takes
Bishop takes Knight White is losing a
piece with this seat this sequence
should be extra careful if you play the
move d3 it's having an impact on the
night on C the knight on c3 is
unprotected another example black just
played the move Queen to d7 how can you
take advantage of this what would you do
is white okay here we go
Queen to g4 seems simple enough right
you might just be of the mentality well
let's connect rooks let's develop but
what what square have you gone to Queen
d7 unprotected square he adds a big
problem white is now not only
threatening mate but after mate is
defended with either f6 or g6 there's
the move Knight h6 check and there goes
the Queen this is a very common motif
this configuration right here Queen
Knight unprotected Queen on d7 some
other arrangement you could see it of
course the different colors
okay-y down move has just played Knight
c4 how can you take advantage of this
black to move okay this is now
unprotected white is creating this
condition by himself one attacker one
defender black can simply take the
knight and pick the bishop up with a
check yeah there goes the bishop another
one white on move has just played Bishop
h6 so what can black play here
okay the bishop on h6 is currently
unprotected and black can capitalize on
this by taking with the knight on f6
this is clearing the way for Queen h4
after it's recaptured Queen h4 lands a
check and there goes the bishop black
has one upon with that sequence so these
last two examples one side or the other
was putting their piece in harm's way
putting it on a square where it's
unprotected another example how many
more do I have five concerning this
unprotected condition last five what do
we have here unprotected pieces yeah
this is a familiar one to be sure after
black plays this last move Queen a5
white to move what's a good move here
okay a good move for white is to unleash
an attack on the Queen and E
addition let's say after f2 d8 light to
move what's a good move it should seem
very familiar to you with that last
example Knight to d5 does the trick here
hitting the Queen and after Queen takes
Queen this is actually just checkmate
last three examples concerning
unprotected pieces and this one is
likely to maybe pose some difficulty for
you
okay anyhow white to move what would you
do okay a good move here is a four what
exactly is a four doing it's pulling a
piece to an unprotected square we're
creating this condition and now playing
the move Queen a3 so this is several
moves deep Queen a3 is hitting the
bishop and after the bishop goes to b5
the only safe Square White has the move
rook takes Bishop unleashing an attack
on the Queen that is unprotected right
when black starts out with the move
Queen d6 you might already start trying
to find ways to take advantage of this
Queen but this is kind of involved
starting out with a four this is a way
to do it though rook takes Bishop after
Queen takes Queen White doesn't
immediately recapture but first inserts
a check if black blocks you take the
rook first and only then are you taking
the Queen after the smoke clears after
these seven moves white has won a minor
piece a bit more sophisticated to be
sure now before I move on to another
topic there's just these last two
examples and the reason why I'm sharing
these two examples is because I want to
let you know that having unprotected
pieces can lead one into and out of a
tactic so for example
people in this position it's white to
move this appears like it's a very good
move the knight has land at a fork it
seems like White's winning material but
there's a way out for black and it's
based on the fact that the rook on a1 is
unprotected the rook can move to a a and
there is no time to take this rook
because black would take actually both
rooks best for white would be to connect
rooks and black is able to save you know
black is not going to lose any material
so unprotected pieces can lead one into
and out of tactics black found a way out
based on an unprotected white rook white
was also tactically vulnerable in that
position and here's one more example
similarly Knights e7 seems great but
black would have a fine move countering
with a pin highlighting the fact that
the Queen is unprotected as well so
these these conditions I'm sharing with
you kind of merge you know we have an
unprotected piece we have a pin going on
and yeah they kind of I kind of overlap
this is a way out for black in this case
so next condition is regarding back rank
weaknesses okay
black out move in this position just
capture the pawn and what do we do we go
down and give check me everybody has
felt this kind of pain and it's
something we can correct pretty easily
right this is where we start to learn
about creating a flight square why did
this what makes a move like this
possible why is this back rank mate
well black doesn't
have adequate defense of the back rank
nor does black have a safe flight square
now this is the primary arrangement that
I think about with back rank mate but
it's not just limited to this
configuration three pawns in front of
the king like this here's some other
arrangements that kind of stick out to
me when I'm looking at a position this
one here right it's kind of like the
same thing there isn't three black pawns
in the King's way but there's a white
pawn that's controlling those squares
black may be vulnerable to back rank
mates there that's a red flag to me in a
position this position right here of
course creating a wall same with a
knight right here and it could also be
just two squares right if the King is on
in the corner square you only have to be
controlling or a black piece just has to
be occupying two squares and just some
other quick arrangements I want to
highlight all of these are instances of
you know they're red flags to me to look
out for some back rank tricks how can I
take advantage of my opponent being weak
on the back rank this is another
arrangement a knight if you could
somehow get to this square here eh
that's going to be checkmate the knight
is is no good defender is of no help to
black and yeah same story here just
working with the King in the corner
here's another one not too common and
rook on g7 like that but okay there's a
back rank mate here a bishop on h7 is
well and okay you get the idea let's
throw some pieces on the board
interesting middle game position alive
okay a lively middle game position efore
was just played takes takes pop quiz
where would you go with the bishop g6 or
h7 feel free to pause the video okay now
there's no one right answer but I just
wanna you know with this I
of back ranked weaknesses I just want to
let you know that in positions like
these if I'm playing as black I'm taking
the back ranked weakness into account I
know that if I put my bishop on h7 one
day I may be vulnerable with my back
rank I don't have that flight square
anymore so I may think more about going
to g6 here I'm not saying one is better
than the other in this position because
there are many other conditions many
other things to factor in about this
position like if you go to g6 do you
really want to have to cope with Knight
h4 with a punch against the bishop
circling into f5 probably not it may be
best to actually do this with the bishop
but I just want to let you know that
this is a thought process that this is
something I think about when it comes
time to make a decision with the bishop
because I felt this pain before of
bringing my bishop here and at some
point it was very uncomfortable when my
opponent got a major piece back here I
might have had to go into a pin block
and yeah I didn't have that square
available so it's something to weigh is
what I'm getting at and it's based on
this back ranked weakness okay another
example here okay pop quiz white to move
what would you do okay very common motif
you can take on f7 and after rook takes
Queen this is leading to checkmate
here's another one
white to move what would you do okay
here we go back rank weakness for black
Queen h4 excuse me Queen a4 is the star
move attacking the Queen attacking an
unprotected rook and if Queen takes
Queen yeah the Queen is a key defender
of the back rank black would be getting
mated
some other move by black in this
position is just gonna end up losing the
rook so no good solution here for black
moving on white to move what would you
do okay back rank weakness here for
black white has a forceful way to win
this one with Queen g7 check rook a a
and black can only block in in the end
everything is white is checking his way
to checkmate okay another one light to
move what would you do okay here we go
rook c8 norc's e8 and after the Knight
takes Queen d8 is checkmate so this
right here kind of sticks out to me at
the start of this position if I could
somehow get here it's gonna be very good
it's gonna be me another example light
to move what would you do okay this
one's a little bit more involved the
star move is rook to d8 well there's a
couple approaches here for black one is
to take it to Queen but if you do that
there's check and then check me the
other approach taking with the bishop
allows the follow-up Queen takes rook
again this is a position an arrangement
that sticks out to me and night on this
square I kind of see this little wall
King takes Queen rook FA is the final
move leading to checkmate
another example after rook to h5 white
to move what would you do
okay here we go Queen f6 Queen is a key
to
the back ranked white is threatening
made on g7 after Queen takes Queen this
is checkmate
another example light to move what would
you do
okay there's a forceful approach here
why can take the rook with's check this
is a very common motif give a check with
the bishop and then give check like so
okay that's basically all the examples I
had regarding back rank mates a back
rank weakness now I'm not limited to
just thinking about back rank weaknesses
let me explain if I'm able to control
this playing as black now if I'm able to
control this G 1 square I start thinking
about not not back ranked weaknesses but
rather a side file I know that sounds
pretty weird side file but yeah if I
could control the G 1 square in this
case if my opponent's king is in the
corner white King in the corner if I can
control G 1 and or excuse me if I could
control G 1 or if my opponent occupies
the square G 1 with their rook now why
rook of all pieces I'll get to that in a
little bit but if I can control G 1 with
a piece or if my opponent occupies G one
with a rook it's a red flag for me to
think about B side file in this case the
H file ok let's see why this is the case
ok there are plenty of tactics that can
come about on the file so these these
arrangements they're red flags to me
King in the corner rook posted like so
let's see why these little rain
engines kind of stick out to me so in
this position it's black to move what
would you do
okay this square is under control
there's a nice sequence here it's a
checkmate in two wing takes a ch2 and we
have something happening on this side
file rook h6 is checkmate and it really
kicks off again for me controlling that
G 1 square or if it's occupied by my
opponent's rook why the rook I'll get to
that shortly in this position light to
move what would you do
okay you probably see the idea by now
this square is under control there's a
nice shot with a queen SAC leading to
mate and in this position right here
light to move what would you do doesn't
always have to be the bishop that
controls this square the knight is doing
that in this case the star moving this
one Queen g6 that's a cool move
if pawn takes Queen it is made on the
spot and if pawn takes Knight there's a
check and a checkmate and one final one
if the F pawn takes the Queen the knight
could take on g6 and in the end we have
this side file me made on the H file
okay so why is it an issue sometimes if
the rook is on this square
well white to move what would you do
okay probably see the idea by now Queen
takes H and then rook h3 checkmate this
is the only piece that is not able to
you know in some cases if the if there
wasn't upon here and you could give a
check any other piece could interpose
somewhere on the H file Bishop a knight
a queen the rook doesn't have that
ability it's just uh you know just
gets in the way of the black king if it
was a knight if it was a bishop they
could move there and then the king could
make use of that g8 square okay a nice
little sequence a checkmate in three
notice doing something slower like this
setting up me something not as forceful
allows black to play Knight here and
cover the h7 square okay moving on to
another example
White's last move Bishop III black to
move what would you do
okay here we go Knight check and a
simple checkmate and I believe this is
the last one the ad is the last one
before we go into this next condition
white to move what would you do okay
Queen takes h7 and oh we have these
other conditions factoring it in this
case white is able to take advantage of
a pin rook h5 is checkmate okay so
moving on to another condition there are
three more I have to share with you this
next one I focus on when playing are
limited pieces now what do I mean by
limited pieces I mean pieces that have
few options and also pieces that have a
defensive responsibility now this first
example black on move if the knight goes
to h5 this Knight is now way short on
squares you know before you make a move
like this as a black you have to
question especially if it's on the edge
you have to question what kind of
mobility does it really have at most if
it's on the edge it has four options but
not here not good options at least
there's no good follow-up move if the
knight is attacked Knight h5 would be
poor g4 is going to take advantage of
this night being short on squares it is
limited
and it's doesn't have many options it is
limited what's happen to look at another
example black plays f6 in this position
the knight is once more stranded white
can play Bishop takes Knight and simply
g4 same story basically as that first
example another one black on move has
just played Knight to e7 white to move
what would you do
okay this one's a little bit different
than the first two blacks last move you
know the night is not limited in any way
really but another piece has been
influenced by blacks last move namely
the Bishop on c5 does not have any safe
Square to move to and is you know
vulnerable to be for White's going to
win a minor piece this is a common thing
you may see I know I've experienced it
at some point or another I've I've done
this and yeah the bishop is vulnerable
it's limited short on squares okay you
also have to question these positions
the Queen gets a little bit aggressive
for a pawn grab deep in the enemy
territory is there a way out this is a
queen trap rook h2 I've had a strong
player fall for this idea before
surprisingly enough I think they were
locked in on a move like rip to g1 but
yeah the Queen would kind of have a way
out but rook to h2 that's you know
queens are goner
now this one this position you see right
here is not nearly as common as this one
well not quite I'm not there just yet
one other position before that one white
to move what would you do
okay best move is B form
the queen is very short on squares from
c5 even though the Queen is still in
blacks house b4 doesn't have many
options the only option is c6 and
yeah that's a problem 97 and there goes
the Queen so the Queen is short on
squares in that case and here's the
example that is very common common Queen
trap the black queen is very short on
squares after the move a6
Queen takes b2 she doesn't have very
many options star move here for wipe is
Knight to a4 and the queen is simply
cooked so what am I getting at here
limited pieces you have to be careful if
you don't have very many options we know
a queen center of the board
no other pieces present Queen has 27
possibilities if she only has like two
or three you better think twice about
putting your queen in that kind of
situation okay limited pieces pieces
that are shortened squares and also
pieces that have a defensive
responsibility black on move in this
position has just given check now if
white takes this pawn the king is now a
defender now I can't speak about this
condition right here without you know
without talking about a keyword that
comes up for me and that is stability
you need to question the stability of
your pieces if you're creating this
situation where you you give one of your
pieces a defensive role well you must
question in this case as white if you're
gonna make this capture you have to
question is my king who is now a
defender stable can I rely upon that
post for my king can my king be
distracted can my king be deflected in
this case yes rook to a4 and then
takes rook black goes on to win in short
a quick little phrase to be familiar
with is defenders the king in this case
get deflected rook a four does the trick
black banks some material defenders get
deflected moving on to the next one
let's see what we have in this position
oh this one's gonna make many of you
cringe you ready for this one yeah after
the move Knight f4 the bishop is
attacked how to defend the bishop what
should you do - about this threat a good
move is to play Bishop to g6
you would just have a pawn around as a
defender here's a move that would make
me cringe if I was observing a game I'd
be very happy to see my opponent play
the move Queen to a5 this is a move if
you were ever considering a move like
this saying oh well I want to develop a
piece and yeah I'll just defend my
bishop yeah you have to question the
stability of this defender now is it
stable absolutely not b4 is gonna hit g4
is gonna hit and yeah Black's losing
material so just wanna throw that one
out there something certainly to shy
away from assigning a defensive role to
your queen yeah you better think twice
about that you have to question the
stability the post of the defender okay
going in going with another one hears a
familiar trick right out of the opening
after the move e5 if black captures on
e5 what has just happened well the black
King now has a responsibility to defend
the Queen and yeah defenders get
deflected
time you can make a capture okay
especially if this is just really new
stuff for you here's a quick tip the
next time you can make a capture instead
of thinking about capturing your
opponent's piece think about the
defender first of that piece and see if
you could deflect it influence it in
some way maybe capture it in this case
Bishop takes f7 pulls the defender away
from the king the defender is deflected
in yeah white wins the Queen a very
simple tactic out of the opening there
let's see about this one yeah I was
talking about defenders getting
deflected here's a case of after the
move Bishop b5 a poor move black and
simply take out the defender of the
bishop Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes
Queen Bishop takes Queen after the smoke
clears if you have lost track Black has
won a minor piece with that sequence
moving on to another one
white on move what would you do okay
here we go
Chuck taking advantage of a pin and you
just take the defender of the Queen with
Chuck and there goes the Queen another
example black to move what would you do
okay the examples I've shared so far our
pieces defending pieces or pawns it
doesn't always have to be like that you
could identify defenders you know
defenders of specific squares and you
could be sure c2 is an important square
to defend if the Queen isn't around
defending c2 Knight c2 is checkmate
so identifying this piece as limited if
the Queen doesn't have so many options
she has a defensive role defend c2 then
move Queen a5 trying to deflect the
defender of c2
at least checkmate and there really
isn't any anything else that I could do
that's so great it's gonna be the loss
of a queen or the king moving on to
another one black to move what would you
do okay
this is known as the Siberian trap best
move is Knight d4 black wants made on h2
and is striking at the Queen and at
night if Knight takes Knight that's
checkmate and if the Queen moves well we
could take the knight with check and
then deliver me after the move Knight d4
black is either going to win the queen
or the king black is deflecting the
defender from the key square h2 moving
on another example how many more about
six black to move what would you do
okay here we go defender b2 if the queen
is not there that's gonna be a problem
it's gonna be checkmate how can you
deflect the Queen well they also are on
the same diagonal that sticks out to me
Bishop g5 is the winner you're gonna
pick up the Queen or give mate once more
like so and if f4 is thrown in you just
take the pawn you are deflecting the
defender of b2 in this case next example
this one could have come about from a
popular game that's out there do you
know what game that is feel free to
comment in the comment section below if
you know how this position could have
come about or from what game is this
position maybe from okay anyhow black to
move what would you do okay the best
move here recognizing that the Queen has
a responsibility the best move is rook
check now if Queen takes rook you give
me
and if ruk takes rook this one's a
little bit deeper now the idea is to now
follow up with Bishop here deflecting
the Queen from the defense of g2 another
example white on move what would you do
okay best sequence the king is the
defender of the Queen how can you
influence that defender first with this
little check it's a one move deeper than
the ones I've already shared check and
yeah there goes the Queen deflecting the
defender white on move has just played
Queen to d2 black to move what would you
do okay best move here is to capture on
h2 White has with this last move created
an overload an overloaded piece the
knight on f3 what's an overloaded piece
a piece that has two jobs too many it
has to watch over not only h2 but also
the Queen and this can be exploited with
this capture on h2 if Knight takes
bishop the queen is lost if King h1
there's a nice discovered check and the
Queen will fall so an overloaded piece
in this example and after black's last
move Queen to d7
there's also another case of something
overloaded in blacks position white to
move what would you do
okay a good move in this position is to
capture on h6 what is the overloaded
piece or pawn in this case it's g7 after
blacks last move the knight lacks some
defense and the lone defender is the
pawn on g7 who has two tasks defend the
knight to fend the pawn after Bishop
takes pawn if this then that white is
winning upon with that sequence another
example the last last hand
here this one should be familiar after
Queen to d7 white to move what can you
do okay here we go
once more there is an overloaded piece
you can take on h7 so it's the same
puzzle basically his two puzzles ago
just from a different angle just some
new pieces involved but the same idea
king in the corner you pick up the queen
with the discovered check and we know
what happens after Knight takes bishop
alright there goes the queen overloaded
pieces
another example straight out of the
opening oh yes this one here this tactic
I'm about to share with you is one that
I have I must have pulled off over a
couple dozen times playing online
what is this tactic exactly
well white on move makes a mistake
very often in this position and it's the
move d4 now if you calculate a little
bit here you know if I if I was to
question if I was if I was to ask you
right now does white have enough support
for efore the answer would seem to be
yes after E for is in if we can count
attackers defenders let's see attackers
1 2 3 defenders 1 2 3 it seems fine but
it is not because after we make a couple
captures like this you'll notice
something at this very moment what is it
exactly
well the rook is now overloaded has to
watch over the Queen has to watch over
the knight white is able to influence
this overloaded piece distract it and
yeah black in the end has 1 upon I have
done this again I'm not exaggerating
when I say a couple dozen times maybe
even more happens quite a bit
okay overloaded pieces I think I'm done
speaking of overloaded pieces I am okay
white to move in this position what
would you do
okay you can create a condition where
your opponent has a defensive role rook
f8 is a star move could only recapture
with the Queen and now we can deflect
the defender of the Queen and white ends
up winning the Queen like so another
example after rook to c8 white to move
what would you do
okay there's a back ranked weakness here
for black so that has my attention and
you could interfere with this with the
move rook c5 if rook takes rook this
will lead to a checkmate and what's
another option for black if Queen takes
rook we take the Queen and basically the
same thing is happening so the star move
here is to influence the defender of the
back rank rook to c5 does this last two
examples concerning limited pieces black
on move has just played rook to e8 white
to move what to do okay here we go best
move is queen g4 with blacks last move
the Queen is the defender we can give a
check and after Queen takes Queen not
recapture straight away we can first
take a rook with check and only then
take the Queen so a little in-between
move is what we call this these
situations where you can take a piece
with check there may be these
opportunities for in between moves Queen
g4 is very nice and only then
recapturing after rook takes rook with
check one last example regarding limited
pieces after rook to b8 white to move
what to do okay similar ideas the last
puzzle this
our move here is queen daddy for looking
to deflect the defender of the rook
there's no good square for the Queen to
go to and still be defending the rook
after Queen takes Queen we insert this
rook takes rook with check move and only
then recapture so limited pieces pieces
that have few squares can be vulnerable
of course and limited pieces I think
about defenders and defenders very often
get deflected influenced in some way now
these last two conditions what are they
exactly well one thing that runs through
my mind our intersection squares now
this isn't necessarily a tactic right
like a a fork or an unprotected piece
this one's kind of tricky for me to
describe I must admit right out of the
gates but it's something that really
does run through my mind when I play
intersection squares what are they well
we experienced this very early on when
we just start out playing with this
scholars mate right
the intersection square in this case is
a square where two or more of your
pieces intersect in this case on f7
looking for me so what am I getting at
here well regarding intersection squares
my eyes are drawn towards key squares in
my opponent's house where my pieces
intersect and also two squares in my
house where my opponent's pieces
intersect so I kind of in other words
think for my opponent as if I was
playing my opponent's pieces I look at
the other side of the board and the
squares where pieces intersect really
have you know I'm really drawn to
those squares more so than any others so
let's have a look at some examples
why is intersection squares something
that sticks out to me well let's start
with this interesting endgame study it's
white to move feel free to pause the
video
that's continuation what is it ok well
the best continuation is well
immediately for me something that's
sticking out is how can you you know
stop the rook from stopping F 8 equals
Queen the way to do that is to interact
with this g2 pond somehow get the knight
on this intersection Square f3 okay the
way forward with this puzzle is to give
a check another check and then after
Knight to f3 white is gonna go on to win
there's no way to stop this pawn from
promoting okay now that was an in-game
study that's so practical this is
something that you would seen in endgame
a very common thing you learned this
very early on as a player and game
situations this square should be
sticking out to you it's a nice way to
interfere with the rook defending the
pawn along a rank that's much more
common than the first example I shared
with the rook being behind the pawn
along a file but yeah this intersection
square certainly something that captures
my attention like to move in this
position what would you do
okay you probably see the idea getting
to this f8 square Y can start with the
check go here in white we'll be getting
a queen no way to prevent that
intersection square this one happened
not too long ago this happened in the
Olympiad 2018 top aboard two
grandmasters playing white did not come
up with the following sequence let's see
if you can spot it like to move what
would you do
okay there is a star sequence that white
could have gone
forward within this position with the
move f7 giving up the rook and then
playing Knight to e8 an interesting move
that not only prevents the rook from
stopping the pond from promoting but the
knight
notice what it is doing it's stopping
the King from coming over to prevent
promotion that is a cool little sequence
and this square here you know once the
pawns are on the seventh rank the second
rank you know those squares on the back
ring kind of stick out to me oh they're
way to put a piece there let's say okay
moving on to another one
black to move in this position what
would you do
okay black on move can give check and
then make use of this square right here
so a bishop in a pond getting to this
square is very often devastating this
one is leading straight to checkmate
another position black to move what
would you do okay with that first
example you're probably seeing the idea
queen pawn in this case getting to this
intersection square e one would be very
good and black can do that first with a
forceful move check and after it is
captured we have checkmate another
example this one's a little bit tricky
black to move what would you do
okay first a check and after the
recapture at this moment the Queen is
the defender of the e1 square it's
indirect but she's still the defender of
that square and black hand play the move
rook d4
deflecting the defense of e1 deflecting
the defender after Queen takes Queen
black promotes with checkmate
so a little in-between move many might
think oh I'd can't go here because after
take stakes
the Queen is recapturing but at this
very moment this is time for a
deflection move queen d4 is nice okay
another one black on move what would you
do
okay this square right here sticks out
to me a knight on once color square the
bishop on the other often interact very
well they intersect well when they're on
opposite colors it's just just how it is
the star move in this position Bishop
takes e2 and after rook takes Bishop the
knight can make use of the f3 square and
then deliver checkmate
another example black to move what would
you do
okay similar idea is the last puzzle
Bishop takes pawn and if Rick takes its
otherwise you're gonna be losing the
Queen you get the idea here Knight d3 in
this case is checkmate white to move
what would you do okay my eye in this
position is drawn to a couple things he
6 and f7 star move in this position as
much as f7 is defended alright how many
defenders four defenders only two
attackers this is still a problem for
black notice also you might want to take
this into account three pieces the
Knights you know same color square rook
takes f7 star move after Knight takes
Knight White has just removed a key
defender of e6 and is able to land a
really nice fork for whatever the reason
I find this kind of tactic pretty cool
with the with the knight in the rock
kind of taking out a key defender and
landing a fork I don't know maybe that's
just me
anyhow intersection square my I was
drawn
to that f-7 square wait to move here not
really uh a pop quiz with this position
a move that I would play in this
position is Knight to a4
avoid the knight exchange and really
start to look at these squares right
here now surprisingly enough there is so
many different ways black can go wrong
in this position one might think well b7
is under fire so I'm gonna defend it
with my queen but that's not a good
defense because you could take on b7 and
after Queen takes there's Bishop takes
c6 that's painful
so let's say black does something
different rook to b8 well there's an
issue with that as well because white
can still take on b7 and then take on c6
and white is doing very well in this
position once more there's a fork on
board and we could even look at
different scenarios like we don't have
to take on b7 first but rather c6 and
after B takes there's Knight takes c6
with the fork so what you were noticing
here is that there are just multiple
ways where tactics can spring about when
you are intersecting on squares in your
opponent's camp especially so when those
intersection squares are right next to
each other there's neighboring square
neighboring intersection squares
adjacent squares b 7 c 6 sometimes f 7 e
6 next example yeah this position right
here I kind of jumped the gun white to
move what's a good move here okay
there's more than one my eye is
certainly focused on f7 it's indirect
right the bishop isn't directly seeing
f7 but that's still a problem ecigs is
hit once indirectly twice a third time
there's something happening here if you
quickly flash you know I if you quickly
flash many of these positions I've
shared with you or to an experienced
player if you were able to monitor their
eyes you can be sure that it's going to
be locked in to certain squares and I
have no doubt that these two stick out
to an experienced player yeah there's an
accident that's going to happen here
accidents happen Hannah at intersections
right yeah there's a problem on a six
you could take like this check let's do
the other one first and you can go with
the night and then go it's check here
and if there there's a checkmate if the
King tries to run there's a check and
then a checkmate let's look at it from a
different angle starting with the bishop
check if the King goes here that's
checkmate and why did I want to do it in
this order because well everybody loves
to see the following sequence right what
is the sequence you'll smothered
checkmate
beautiful right so another example white
pieces intersecting in blacks camp on
multiple squares squares that are right
next to each other there's multiple you
know sequences you could pull off
multiple combinations for white that are
appealing there very good okay another
example what do we have here okay yes I
remember there's just so many of these
yeah at this point right here
white on move this is not a good choice
oops this move here not a good choice a
good move is Bishop to e3 simply
developing defending this isn't a bad
move a losing move in any way but I just
want to bring to your attention one of
the thoughts I have when my opponent
opponent makes a move like this I'm
taking with the b-pawn and why am i
taking with the b-pawn while I want to I
don't want to exchange Queens for one
I'm taking in this direction and I'm
thinking I'm already about converging
one day on b2 and I know that it's going
to be difficult
at some stage more likely than not for
white to defend that point and that's
just kind of how it is when you you know
strike at your opponents at a specific
point from different angles right along
a file a diagonal or ranked something
interesting is nearby so let's see how
play develops a little bit more it's not
going to take long for a tactic to hit
after rook to b8 in this position it's
super easy for white to go wrong
b-2s under-fire c3 has a some attention
b2 has some intention if looked to be
one in this position that's a losing
move because of Bishop takes c3 take
with the pawn you lose the rook you take
with the Queen
what black can exchange and then take
the rook rook to b1 in short is not a
defense and there's even another
sequence and reply to rook to be one
well you also you can't do this you just
drop the knight another sequence in
reply to rook to b1 is to actually take
on B to first just changing a move order
a little bit after rook takes there's
Bishop takes c3 there goes the Queen
yeah a lot of different combinations can
come about when your pieces are kind of
focused on these intersection squares
okay black to move in this position what
would you do
okay best move here is Knight to e3 so
so far I've really been focused on
pieces intersecting in a opponent's
pawns or pieces but it doesn't have to
be that way it could just be you know
focusing on a vacant Square night to e3
is one example of that Knight on e3 rook
on e3 Bishop on e3 why is this such a
good move in this case well for one its
landing a fork it's gonna win some
material and if the knight is captured
there goes the Queen this is
sticks out to me you may you know if it
was white I'll move right now after the
move h3 you may be thinking well gotta
go back
you know maybe think forward if you're
if you're connecting very well like this
there may be something interesting
93 is a very good move in this position
all right here's another angle position
has just shifted ever so slightly
instead of Queen on d2 its on d3 there's
no pawn on d3 black on move can play the
same move Knight e3 once again with a
fork
if pawn takes you don't take with the
bishop in this case but rather the rook
hitting the Queen and after the Queen
moves there's a discovered check takes
discovered check takes the knight with
this sequence Black has won a couple
pawns and is winning in this position
another example how many do I have about
five more concerning intersection
squares black to move what would you do
okay this is a nice interference tactic
I think basically everything is on the
square c4 Black has two pieces on that
yeah I believe every experienced player
has fallen fallen for something like
this and then yeah you're just aware
from it from that point on moves like
this are available 9 c4 was checked
there's now a disconnect with these
rooks and blacks is gonna be winning the
rooks or something like pawn takes King
takes rook if you take the knight with
the knight of the pond there's King
takes rook and something like this
you're you're winning some material ok
intersection square C 4 in this case
sticks out to me in this position black
to move what would you play okay this
isn't a winning contained continuation
nor was the previous puzzle but yeah
this square right here D form really
sticks out to me pawn Knight rooks
on that square this move is available
after pawn takes knight black intake
striking at the bishop and if the bishop
moves there would be the move d3 this
isn't a winning continuation black can
play rook to d2 and we have a bunch of
exchanges it's roughly an even position
but I just wanted to make you aware that
moves like this are possible this
doesn't necessarily have a you know a
great name but yeah these tactical ideas
are present in there you know if you're
focused on intersection squares you may
be more inclined to spot them okay
another example this is from one of my
own games unfortunately I did not reply
well to the move b4 what move should I
play in this position okay I should have
made the move Knight to d5 and this
takes into account something more than
just an intersection Square yeah there's
a lot of pieces on board still all
pieces on board the bishop on e7 is
unprotected Knight to d5 would have been
a wonderful move if pawn takes Knight I
take with the epon hitting both bishops
what did I end up doing something lame I
went backwards but okay had I been a
little bit more attentive to this
intersection Square again this is a
faster time control game but still yeah
1985 would have been a very nice move
there's so much stuff concentrated on
that Square last three examples white to
move what would you do okay this may be
surprising to you but I wouldn't be you
know ask some experienced players show
them this position and watch how quickly
they come up with a move like Bishop to
h6 just kind of out of the blue it seems
that you're not capturing anything if
there was a pawn here you'd be much more
inclined to just chop away but yeah even
just going here even though you're not
taking anything is a star move
intersecting on g7 let's look at a
couple variations if pawn takes Bishop
there's Queen takes and there's not
really a great way to be defending this
Knight H flat Knight h5 excuse me
defends you can look to deflect white is
for choice here white is winning another
variation might be to defend like this
directly but you can take and then
deliver maintenance keep in mind there's
also a pin going on here
there's no pawn advance to help to have
the Queen help defend g7 white is mating
from this position but yeah it's all
kicking off with some attention to this
h6 square kind of a bolt from the blue
last two examples you know I've been
paying a lot of attention to what my
pieces are doing in my opponent's
position but again I also have some
focus on what my opponent's pieces are
doing in my house
so white on move in this position has
just captured the knight now my question
to you is in what way should you
recapture and your choices are Knight or
bishop feel free to pause the video okay
the best way to recapture is with the
knight now what's the issue is taking
with the bishop well what we're going to
observe is that it's very important to
keep defended over d6y well there's an
issue on the b v square this should
certainly capture your attention this
intersection square and b5
a lot of the white pieces are trained on
that point even though there's a pawn
there supporting there would be an issue
white could follow up with Bishop takes
b5 and computer suggests rook to b8 is
best what's the issue with capturing
well this night goes on a rampage taking
upon hitting the Queen take another pawn
with check the
castled and then the bishop gets the
door slammed in its face
White has just won three ponds
established a monster night on d6 the
black king is on Castle the rook is
having a tough day at the office on a
che what is this what makes this tactic
available well what would keep you from
recapturing with the bishop is some
attention to the b5 square these
tactical possibilities on the be 5
square and circling in to d6 you could
even consider d6 as an intersection
square once the night is on b5 this can
be a big problem
okay last example concerning
intersection squares black to move what
would you do
okay best to move in this position is to
capture on e5 with check the square that
sticks out to me in this position where
my pieces do well interacting with one
another is on the D 2 square and not
just the knight and the rook however
indirect it is the Queen has some
influence on that square after Knight
takes e5 one of the barriers are removed
with the Queen Singh that Square rook to
d2 have to take and in the end Queen
takes Bishop for checkmate this was a
checkmate in three puzzle now my final
point to share with you is the letter C
and the letter C stands for checks
captures and checkmate threats checkmate
in Ex threats checkmate 1 checkmate -
okay checkmate in Ex threats these are
the most forceful moves in the game
checkmate threats
checks captures in some order what
have just outlined here if you haven't
noticed already I have created an
acronym for you that I believe will be
helpful this acronym is public and it's
a fitting one this is a youtube video
this is free to everybody to view and
keep in mind that this acronym public
position of pieces pins unprotected
pieces back ranked weaknesses limited
pieces intersection squares checks
captures checkmate threats this is not
some master list okay this is maybe for
you some starting point for improving
your tactical vision this is something
that you can maybe build on okay so this
is just something to get you started
just a little appetizer here so let's
have a look at some examples now as a
close concerning checks captures and
checkmate threats so white in this
position has just played the move d3 and
we're seeing these conditions come
together in a very simple way white has
an unprotected Bishop white has with
this last move just opened up a diagonal
this is the first moment where white is
now vulnerable to a check and yeah we
see these combined and now a check is on
board we pick up a bishop we saw this
much earlier on but at the time I did
not reference checks yeah a simple
tactic involves a check and an
unprotected piece there's a million
different possibilities when you keep
those two conditions in mind moving on
to another one
Bishop c6 is throwing a punch at the
pond
pop quiz to you how to defend a form
okay a way to defend it is Bishop to d3
that's a fine way to do it queen the e3
is another one what is not a good way in
this case is to play f3 move your F pawn
you're going to be vulnerable to a
diagonal check if your castled yeah it's
gonna be a problem that it would be a
problem here to a simple check and yeah
what is just dropped upon so careful are
you making a move that is creating an
unprotected piece are you making a move
that is allowing your opponent to
deliver a check these are things to look
for before you even make one of your own
moves
okay this position is one that I played
as white line my opponent played f6 I
was not alert enough to a nice tactical
sequence let's see if you can spot it
like to move okay this one has to do a
little bit with move order a couple
different captures you can go forward
with but the best way to approach this
is to take the bishop first as soon as
f6 is played I should have been thinking
much more along you know getting a piece
to this diagonal rook takes Knight and
then Queen c4 in the end a check and the
bishop can be picked up this would have
meant a nice sequence to win two pieces
for the rook why does the better side
why does the winning side with this
sequence now let me be
a little bit exact here if there are
checks if there are captures checkmate
in Ex threats this doesn't mean you know
there are very forceful moves to be sure
but this this does not mean that you
should be going for these moves if you
if you can make these moves you're not
just going to check just because you can
just because you know your opponent
doesn't have as many options that's not
always the best thing to do you always
want to have the end result be something
positive for you if you could Bank some
material okay yeah that's certainly
something to go forward with but yeah
there'll be plenty of instances where
giving check isn't leading to anything
good for you we're making a capture
isn't benefitting you in any way you
want to benefit in some way with these
ideas white to move in this position
what would you do okay a simple move
here is to attack the bishop that is
unprotected and if the Queen can get to
FA that would be checkmate like it
combined these two ideas pointing at an
unprotected piece and threatening a
checkmate in one there's just no good
solution here for black computer says
give a check and do something like this
or maybe move the Queen but this isn't
this isn't going to end well either this
is one way the game kid go straight to
checkmate black has to just give all the
pieces away but the main idea at least
at the start of this one is to recognize
the bishop as a bit vulnerable and these
squares here right around the king is
their way to intersect with the rook and
there is f8 Queen c5 does the trick so
again you shouldn't just check just
because you can you want to benefit in
some way I'm not sure I actually I blame
I blame the commercials that are out
there or the films that are out
highlighting two players play check oh
excuse me play chess and yeah it seems
to always involve one player saying
check in the clip and the other player
reacting like oh I'm really scared you
know I mean I'm in a tough spot check
isn't always a good thing and this is a
perfect example all right this is a case
where yes I would welcome check thank
you so much rip b1 oh you're gonna give
a check again thank you again
oh you're inviting me to the g4 square I
wanted to be here anyway I wanted to
help escort my pawn to promotion land
perfect example where these checks do
absolutely nothing for black again you
want to get something positive if you're
gonna go forward with these checks
another example just about a dozen left
are you still with me if you still are
give yourself a pat on the back you have
a lot of patience I've said this in
previous videos that have gone on for
well over an hour yeah if you're still
with me you have a lot of patience and
yeah that's a wonderful attribute to
have as a chess player okay my question
to you in this position is is it
worthwhile to insert this check before
capturing the pun yes or no feel free to
pause the video okay the answer to this
is no bishop check first allows the King
to move in the direction he would like
to be towards the center so black has
simply helped the King this is still an
even position regardless of you know
going here straight away or capturing
the pond but these little details can
factor in and getting a little bit
technical now I realize but yeah another
position the only thing that has changed
is the knight is now on f1 same question
is it worthwhile to insert the check
before taking the pawn feel free to
pause the video Oh
yes it is and you could probably
understand why the king is now
inconvenienced has to go away from where
he would like to be namely in the center
of the board okay so we're going to
consider checks we're going to consider
captures but this doesn't mean you we
should actually follow through with
these things another example what do we
have here oh yes something much more
practical how many of you in this
position playing is white maybe played
the move Bishop to b5 check just because
you love to give check if you're making
a move like this there's a strong chance
you haven't seen the video where I
covered good and bad bishops Bishop b5
is a poor move in this position for
multiple reasons one you are expediting
blacks development and two you are
allowing the trade of blacks bad bishop
for your good Bishop no good you gain
nothing with that sequence okay white to
move in this position what would you do
okay best sequence here is to give a
check on b1 looks like it's a ridiculous
move but after Queen takes Queen there
is no longer a pin white can now promote
with a queen and win the Queen so a
little bit of a spectacular looking move
something a little bit unexpected right
giving check and allowing your queen to
be captured but okay it has its points
here of course another example light to
move what would you do okay
we have to consider checks captures
first we're not always going to pull the
trigger but in this case f7 is the only
check most forceful move and regardless
of how the black King works to me how
black recaptures it's going to lead to
mate King takes allows rook F 1 and then
rook to f8
and if Bishop takes we're gonna have the
rook go to the back rank the rook could
block first but we just take away and in
the end or once more giving checkmate
another example light to move what would
you do okay this is a pretty cool
sequence once more my eye is drawn to
this square f7 intersection square this
is a star move and after rook takes King
Knight Queen can't quite land a fancy
fork just yet but the ensuing Queen
takes h6 is very nice
after King takes Queen the conditions
are now set for a knight fork Knight
takes rook Knight takes Queen in the end
White has won a couple pawns okay
another example white to move what would
you do
okay here we go don't be too tempted to
simply give a check and win the bishop
wherever the knight goes it's check the
most forceful move here is to land a
double check less to calculate for sure
when your opponent is in double check
you can be assured the King has to go
somewhere if it's not already checkmate
the King must move and double check
Knight g5 is the star move in this
position if the King goes back that's
gonna be checked me and if the King goes
to h6 see the move here cool move rook
h7 and after Bishop takes rook the King
is sandwiched on the H file that's a
cool mate another example final five Wow
how far we have come white to move what
would you do okay
white on move can sacrifice the Queen
these crazy
need to be calculated there often a very
forcing move doesn't have many options
have to take the Queen or go back if you
go back you're getting mated
straightaway White has enough material
to sacrifice the Queen rook check pawn
takes sacrificing a rook even check and
now checkmate
that's a pretty cool sequence you know
the if you're able to force the king up
the board you might not need as much
material as you might think you could
afford to give up your queen in this
spectacular way black to move in this
position what would you do
okay you're probably seeing a pattern
now queen g2 is the star move have to
take the Queen it looks crazy but yeah
you could follow up with another check
and your black is simply checking his
way to check me in this case final four
light to move what to do
okay star move here another Queen
sacrifice I'm pretty much closing out
this video with some spectacular moves
these are all these past few have all
been played in games pulled straight
from games Queen in the corner a check
and regardless of how black blocks
Bishop to e5 is not quite checkmate then
you have your pick checkmate let's go
with the pawn that looks cool
white is winning looking first at the
checks black on move in this position
what to do okay I think this is the
final one where we have a queen
sacrifice Queen to h2 of all moves not
capturing anything but it's certainly
the one that limits White's replies in
the best way there is only one option
you might as well first consider those
moves to follow up with a check
another check only moves in every case
for white thus far and black has the
time to make a quiet move in the end
rook to e2 and there's no good defense
to rook g2 for checkmate white has to do
something like that but we just pick up
the Queen and yeah pick your favorite
move as white rook g2 next is checkmate
no I actually lied there still some more
examples here white to move what would
you do okay some still some more flash
to go star move is to sacrifice the rook
only one reply the Queen only one reply
and now we have a cool double check MN
checkmate
final puzzle final pop quiz really is
this one right here and then just some
kind of closing remarks white to move
what would you do
okay white on move pretty neat sequence
clean G for Bishop takes Queen this one
takes some visualization to be sure
black can also sacrifice the rook have
to take like this only one reply and
then the final move killer bees are
delivering checkmate can't even
interpose and you certainly can't
capture the bishop so I believe that's
all the pop quizzes I have for you just
some closing remarks here we were
looking at a ton of specifics concrete
variations through a ton of pop quizzes
your way I just want to share some some
of the reasoning that goes into certain
moves with these last few examples white
on move in this position has just played
king day each one
it's not a best move but I just want to
highlight why a move like that would be
played King to h1 is what I would
identify as a preparatory move it is
preparing to play the pawn up to f3 or
even more aggressively f4 and white does
not want to one day be subjected to a
check along this diagonal it may not
always be the case the bishop is around
to secure that diagonal it's kind of
thinking a bit deeper we can't always
anticipate how things will evolve in the
middle game how crazy it's going to get
so before you play a move like f4
sometimes you might want to tuck the
King away and then only make this much
more committal move like f4 this is
taking into account the check condition
white doesn't want to be subjected to a
check somewhere down the line another
example just going straight from the
opening this is one of the one of the
thoughts I have with this next move
after white plays f4 the move c5 is a
good reply now there are many reasons
why this is the case but the one that
I'm thinking about right I can't say the
one I'm thinking about most but okay one
of the reasons that I make a move like
c5 well what am I trying to do well I'm
already anticipating the king is going
to Castle one day right he can't stay in
the center he's gonna have to be on g1
and when he's on g1 these two pawns kind
of act as barriers to checks by the
bishop or the Queen and I know if I
could remove at least one of those two
barriers it's much more likely that
maybe a check something exciting
something good for black will happen
along this diagonal okay final position
is this one here not just looking at
yeah I don't have the full moves of this
game but this one I played very recently
as black and I made a poor move in this
position now before I share with you
what this poor move is I'd like to
highlight what the computer is
suggesting in this position the top two
suggestions by the computer rh6 can you
see why a move like that would be played
well it's creating a flight square for
the King and we know that if there's a
flight square here black isn't more than
likely won't have to worry of back rank
mates another move is suggested by the
engine rook F to e8
now this last move may strike many as
what exactly is that doing right you're
going from a closed file to another
closed file but there's a very important
point behind that I want you to observe
the value in other words in rook to f8
rook F to ei there is value in
protecting a piece that was unprotected
this is kind of like yeah black is once
more preparing for something volatile
some something crazy is going to happen
soon in the center it's going to break
open at some stage and if your pieces
are unprotected you're going to be
vulnerable let me show you how I was
very vulnerable in this position I
didn't make a prep move like h6 creating
a flight square or I move like rook to
e8 and you would maybe even go one step
further let's say the King goes here you
might even tuck the bishop away what did
I do the move I played was D five my
quick thought this was a faster game but
my quick thought was okay let's break
the position open I have enough support
for d5 let's just play d5 but my quip my
opponent was
responded very well here captured a
bunch of times but in the end Wow look
at this position I'm in you ready
unprotected Bishop unprotected Knight
the other bishops unprotected and my
opponent followed up very nicely Knight
to f5
there is simply no good solution forming
everything is hanging bishop is hanging
with a fork other bishops hanging and
yeah there's just no good solution to
this one right I move like this seems to
defend everything right but then we
realize yeah this remember that night on
a light square yeah he's he's quite the
pest that would be a cool move for white
and a very painful one for me team black
here okay it didn't go in that direction
but yeah I was in serious hot water
after moved Knight to f5 losing position
for me so as a close to this video what
do I have to share well again if you're
still with me right now if you went
through this whole thing wow you have a
lot of patience and again it's a
wonderful attribute to have as a chess
player this list that I shared with you
is again not some master list this may
be something that is a starting point
for you something for you to build on
these are skills these conditions I've
shared with you being attentive to the
position of pieces unprotected pieces
back rank weaknesses etc this is a skill
you can develop and with some practice
you're going to find that your eye for
identifying tactical moves significantly
improves now I have some suggestions for
you with how you can maybe achieve this
skill and it's not going to come by
playing fast time control games if
you're going to develop these
skills you have to think you have to
think and you have to think slowly about
these things you have to play slower
time controls is what I'm getting at
my suggestion is 15-minute games with
increments maybe do one a day or two a
day 15 minute with a 10 second increment
is a wonderful time control getting in a
couple like that every day you could
really start to develop these skills and
I don't think it is realistic for you to
go into this with you know what I'm
gonna focus on all of these conditions
that I highlighted I just I just don't
think that that's realistic so what's my
suggestion well my suggestion is for you
to go into a game or two or you know
focus on any one of these points for
let's say a week two weeks however long
it takes for you to maybe kind of
develop a skill and identifying these
things instinctually focus on any one of
these things when you're playing your
game focus on pins go into a game saying
you know I'm really gonna be attentive
to me having my opponent in a pin or me
being in a pin I'm gonna try and find
ways to exploit this and you know same
story with unprotected pieces and you
know the list goes on the list is there
for you your acronym is public it's for
everybody so I'm not sure or what more
to add I have notes here in front of me
I'm just kind of skimming right now I
think I covered everything I imagine
when I do the editing this video I will
have included notes on the side if I've
missed something but yeah okay I'm
babbling at this point this video has
gone on long enough as usual I hope you
benefit in some way from this and yeah
that's the intention with this beginner
to chess master playlist so
as usual I hope you got something out of
this video and I look forward to
continuing this series and producing
video 28 in time that's all for now
take care bye
you